hey hey we're the Monkees and we're
gonna get [ __ ] up
welcome to another episode of impaired I
am your first show Stacey Cariah
to my right I am Crisco he's a huge
pothead I'm an alcoholic you probably
watched an episode we're gonna bring our
friends on we're gonna play a game
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys here we are
give it up for guess everybody Brandon
Janney coming in hot and having some fun
you guys already having fun yeah of all
they're having a couple of drinks
already which is pretty fun
we are always good when people come in
and start drinking before we're taping
this episode I'm double-fisting I'm
smoking weed
nice little vape celebrating something
for this guy please don't let them see
this and this old face just did new
faces in how drunk did you get so
goddamn all you do is get [ __ ] up it's
so [ __ ] up it's kind of scary too
because then you're like I like shaking
hands with people oh yeah you're like oh
I'm so-and-so from so-and-so no my my
manager's name is Vince my agents name
is Justin I'm gonna walk away my cards
gonna make ourselves no no thank you
I felt like I only talked to me when
they came up to me so yeah like I met
Jay Sierra was that a grizzly bear that
I just you will be out of your bear
you'd be a Kodiak if I can love that I
like that better
I know and the Kodiak sir oh yeah all
right guys we always like to open the
show with a little a little mix shot so
a foreman of these tall glasses because
it's what we got well he's doing that
I'm gonna explain one of the first games
were gonna play throw the entire legs of
the episode it's called secret word when
the secret word is uttered you will hear
this phrase at that point everybody gets
to everybody it's a drink if you want
but the person who said it gets to
really drink and courtesy Banzai vapes
thank you very much for sponsoring Spa
first buzz the winner whoever's gets the
secret word gets to keep this full
Graham cartridge of Snoop Dogg oh gee by
bonsai vapes
I've heard of him I think he likes weed
and this cartridge was acquitted of
double homicide
thank was the case that they gave me hey
cheers guys welcome to the show thank
you guys oh yeah all right no not a fan
garbage
whoa I like that I like the initiative
you don't want not
it smells like cleaner hard pass by
Jenny
I'll give the recipe now how do you make
that pile of trash that's right that
pile of garbage was made with Three
Olives ginger Ale's magic ran splash of
Malibu rum cording to Jenny a splash of
dog it was trash we made such a big bowl
of [ __ ] we're gonna call that shot which
I think I don't know if anyone's a
minute we're calling cuz she missed her
mouth entire low and they're drinking my
way before the show how can you blame
the shopping all right we'll move it on
rats hilarious that is you know it done
really I'm actually happy I have a very
absorbent bra hey we had no response we
decided not to wear a bra it's a while
the internet was talking about it a
little bit yeah shout out to Heather
killing the game killing the game all
right we're gonna move on to one of our
favorite things we like to do a little
intoxication stories I think it's a good
way for everybody out there to kind of
like see what way you like to get [ __ ]
up does anyone wanna start normally
we'll start with coppa dope over here
how am I start ready go for it baby okay
this was probably about ten years ago I
was on the road I was in lakeland
florida which is a very terrifying thing
to start Annie Annie at one door
Lakeland Florida was the crystal meth
capital of the world but the story is
not go down
he literally went I was in Lakeland
Florida any time say that it sounds like
an episode of the 48 I was in Lakeland
officer Jim Janssen was on the scene
with a - no I got very drunk on stage I
got so drunk on stage that I kind of
blacked out which is I don't do that
very often and I did my said he's a
black no no I can move like ow I woke up
prompt in the toilet like I've been
throwing up and I just got myself where
I could hold and just I didn't say our
heads gigantic or you would have been
drowned in a toilet no I was at the top
of it no bread would be dead the worst
part it's me in a toilet was when I come
out of the bathroom when I come out of
the bathroom the other two comics are
sharing the room with me what you know a
Lakeland what did you kill Tinley no man
I met a Days Inn with a comedy called
Google GZ the nobody said I'm staying
with you like two comics doubled up in
one bed I had my own but I slept in the
bathroom so when I come out the first
thing they start doing is go so how much
last night do you remember and I was
like that's very little wide bad the
Omega because the Booker's tried to call
here four times to talk to you and I was
like did I get too drunk on stage and
they go yes but you also chose to use
some choice verbage while you're on
stage that offended a certain cried kind
of group did you something come out hard
Crisco just go on for four hours until
they finally told me they're breaking my
balls I just got drunk in that was it
they convinced I was expecting a phone
call getting fired for my comedy
blackout drunk you're capable people
jump my [ __ ] bridges when they're
drunk so to tell me that I was like oh
maybe I don't [ __ ] know oh my god
[ __ ] pull a Roseanne yeah man I'm 22
I don't think anymore
I didn't say anything but they just had
me convinced they're like a kid but you
said it man I was like I would have
blackmailed you
be here I was like I almost called the
Booker and like to to try like call him
back and they're like no no I would wait
for him that's what in the comedy
community call those people friends yeah
our friends did that yeah that's and I
mean honest Adam that's one the reasons
why don't get too hammered that often
but yeah it's otherwise angry when I'm
onstage if I get drunk before a show I
get me a dress angry or aggressive yeah
and I do this I do this that's not I do
this that's that's I'm gonna tell you
something and then I and then I just get
me and and like really aggressive so I I
have a rule I don't drink before a show
period I know you don't want to like you
won't drink at all the course show got
it yeah when I was a teenager so I never
got oh I've dive done terrible things
amateur show you look like a child we
get it you're human one's gonna hand me
a drink yeah you're gonna get carded to
your hydrant yeah so much before show
sometimes tipping point you're gonna be
like it like like 37 wrinkled hair
you're gonna wake up and just be dog
you're look like like they can make a
picture of Tom Cruise and Kelly McGinnis
and got on the internet but they're both
gonna be of you great reverence cause
this is a center Dog the Bounty Hunter
Jesus so I got six years tell your dog
the battery I saw it with the wrong
feather earrings and the mullet I see it
renegade it blaze that's a good look
you're going to Coachella
or if you're hunting people and ye
outside right in my story yeah daddy go
for this started out um okay I'm trying
to think we want to do
I love hallucinogenics that's alright
saris well ok I I'll do choose it
doesn't matter I don't know ok I did
mushrooms a month ago okay the desert
which one which one which one or my
ayahuasca experience so I mean which one
I mean I feel like I've never stays on
episode Chrissy he gets very allergic to
mind-expanding drugs that's not true we
haven't had an ayahuasca story so that
before I saw I did ayahuasca a few years
ago because I wanted to try to solve
some problem right to expand your mind
don't do that so when you do ayahuasca
you have to follow specific rules like
you have a vegan diet three days
beforehand not you're also supposed to
abstain from sex you're supposed to
abstain from like violent like so of
course like the day I did it
I [ __ ] had bacon oh no I had a huge
fight with my sister I was like well
time to go tripping to pay a canyon time
to drink a cup full of awesome crazy
juice so I did it and it was with a
bunch of people in this cabin in Topanga
Canyon I feel like that always hurts
like tripping experiences too when
there's like [ __ ] too many people
well ok so you would think that ok but
everyone is like in their zone like you
you do the shaman does whatever he does
you go and you take it and then you go
straight back like just a touch other
common situation so I didn't know about
this job
ah yeah to do these drugs this sounds
like a procedure is there an oddball
shop it's not it's not like a fun let's
go laugh with a friend of thing does he
accept a PPO what kind of interchange I
got free healthcare okay so this is
shaman so we go into the thing and then
like there's more like ten of us in this
room and then we go to where our mats
where we were just supposed to hang out
and like go throw [ __ ] and I remember at
one point like it's nighttime you do it
at night
and then I remember looking out to like
where all my friends were and they were
gone they just disappeared I did not see
anybody a new realm I was like I really
it was crazy I did literally disappear
you were talking the Sun rattles so I'll
get to the freckles over so fraggles
fragment fraggle check it out so I was
sitting there and then people are
vomiting around you like who doesn't
like cuz I want a side effect yeah you
vomit and you [ __ ] man oh man this
sounds like a [ __ ] row shindig so you
need four guys in a room they're gonna
give you two buckets one of them one of
them say they're very very
thank you [ __ ] in the bathroom they have
a bathroom there that's good I don't
trust anything so I remember like people
were literally vomiting around me like
as they're having these breakthroughs
but I remember like I'm not gonna vomit
I'm better than all these people and
then being like oh no it's real and then
you like are done it at this point where
like you're like flying through fractals
it's insane it's the most beautiful
feeling
I forgot how to wrap a blanket around me
that's like I had a blanket in front of
me and I was like I'm so cold and I
couldn't figure out how to put the
blanket around my body I said we're like
calling at this blanket
25 try how did you manage this
wait so then the shaman so then okay
where my friends were a shaman it scares
me because I feel like he's gonna do
something creepy
the shaman turned into the devil icon
from a tarot card it's like half person
half goat and then a tree came out of
the ground that was full of like bloody
limbs like um oh my god what was that
movie with Johnny Depp oh no no the
other one absolutely be Hollow Sleepy
Hollow that just sprouted out of the
ground but I remember watching it man
like this is so [ __ ] funny this is
hilarious you're describing a scene out
of the film like drag drag me to hell
and then but I was like this is so funny
Jenni is this funny this is hilarious
like sorry yeah so I was like saying to
myself I was like I'm eternal love and
this is [ __ ] hilarious
and then my spirit animal showed up who
was an owl and what is that well then
later on I realized it was the
refrigerator lighter light it was
refrigerator light not an owl and that
was not an owl but still you know
whatever I'm gonna say it's an animal
I'm gonna say it was an owl so it was
terrible I took a big old [ __ ] and that
I had a and then I had some
breakthroughs in the bathroom and they
had to come get me like cuz they have
like from somebody's not being like
watching yes I went to the bathroom did
a [ __ ] and then I when were just pacing
around the bathroom having my
revelations and then someone had to come
and get me so I think I was probably in
there for like an hour just like talking
to it so that's the thing like what so
in the end did you really have some like
weird like like realization I saw the
connections are connected everyone yeah
and that connected all the all the the
beings in the world
I had this revelation through life where
it at one point I was like I don't want
to do this anymore and there was a voice
I was like you have to go through this
you have to do this that's what life is
is going through that you don't want to
do but doing it and like coming through
a better person and that was the thing I
took away from it but also like holy the
devil was talking you went through a
weird Tim Burton nightmare and at the
end of it you went in the end we're all
the same and molecules are good I wanted
to figure some [ __ ] out and there was
this voice skipping like you're a
comedian you're a comedian that's cool
that's what you're supposed to do kept
being like but I want to figure [ __ ] out
and the brain was like nah [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
right look at this funny look at this
funny devil that's just I don't see the
funny of the devil being funny a devil
shows up on a weed trip I'm just scream
if you're gonna do ayahuasca stick to
the [ __ ] diet don't [ __ ] anybody like
just stick to the rules you can actually
have a drug requires you to be a praise
cheering you know what guys if we can't
say sobriety you learn stuff
don't [ __ ] dony bacon before ayahuasca
and that's then you won't see the devil
and that'll be fun it's like Coachella
it was like Coachella careful guys you
want to follow that with something but
all right so I'm booting heroin to the
gas station for I can follow to view our
buddy Glee Wiggly in Athens Georgia
I got a loser the gin story as well you
want to go ahead let's do it but not
props all right so you guys this is the
story the first time I got drunk got
understand my background there okay 30
[Music]
how old are you 19
yeah so my parents are very sober people
like they would buy a case of beer
because there was a free hat inside and
then they dump the beer cuz it would
expire okay so that was my upbringing
right like my dad would let me taste his
beer but that was just because he wanted
me to finish it for him right here so
you throw it out get the Hat very sober
upbringing
that's a weird dad he was a good guy
there's weird dads out there yeah Mary
Biddle comes oh man I lived close to the
Canadian border sweetie I'm sorry did
you just
I didn't lick it you taught you
separated then you eat your side and
then you just toss it like it's a
[ __ ] all in poker chip what do you
want from me
you know what I love about Chris cope
it's the details guys he finds the
details and you know he likes to do
interrupts people without goddamn racing
story and let that unprofessional
content something you learn from doing
Iowa Cassidy Oreo you just need the
cream side yeah life is about getting
the cream I just I just couldn't handle
that grace so I'm 19 and and me and my
buddy go up to Canada and we go up there
and drink for the first time and my dad
like he was the sweetest guy had no idea
he was like a pervy dude back in his
college days he like told me all the
strip clubs
yeah the pervy dude knew in detail I
like you the pervy dude yes the
strippers that go to Jason's they have
really nice leather Kawai what's sitting
hold on easy for them to white
the jizz away and get in their brain
we're basketball short wear no underwear
well you can come through the fat look
if you're gonna wear jeans why go you
can't feel them rubbing on it
don't put your keys in your pocket
that's where your [ __ ] all right Brett
so there you go we go and and the women
who were working there they look like
they had been there since my dad was
there and so my buddy
yeah it was Windsor
I'm going to win Christmas what Canada
what city was with Jays is in what
Canada Ontario province you mean my
problems yeah Ontario yeah right
okay oh hi Ohio it's close sorry that's
why I got my passport was just to go up
there couches just to get my hands on
those leather couches right but come on
so we ended up getting thrown out
because my buddy had already we'd been
drinking a lot because we'd never really
yeah you know we were invited before
yeah and it's the beer up there's a lot
stronger and and so he was like to the
point where his blackout drunk and he
was getting a lap dance and he started
screaming at the lady just like vagina
going oh I see the crabs coming out or
Sebastian came over and they kicked us
out son you can't you can't tell the
people what she has
well the dragon that was he singing
urgency honestly if that happened if I
was at a strip club and crabs came out
of Oklahomans vagina and started singing
songs from Little Mermaid I'd tip more
well that's worth of ten that's a start
an Etsy store yes oh my god
we're selling the crapster toilet and
people buy those Etsy stores see you got
did you get booted out where's your
buddy
we got booted out and I just I don't
remember her a lot cuz you know I was
drunk yeah I just remember like our
other friend couldn't go cuz he couldn't
find his birth certificate and he was so
sad so he called us and he was just
bragging oh yeah dude we've had like 6
million beers and we're just having the
time of our life and then his girlfriend
called him he's like oh no we only have
like two beers we're good like this is
wait wait who said this my buddy
Sebastian the crab okay Sebastian said
Sebastian to his girlfriend we only had
two beers yes but - your friend was like
we're living our best miles miles you're
a [ __ ] liar you piece of [ __ ]
breaking currency piece of [ __ ] miles he
could have got jacked off with speaking
and then stop get a guy jacket sometimes
I kept all that's right that's right I'm
doing some things now you're catching
yourself at just the right time I got a
hallucinogen story - first I'll say
normally our show sponsored by straws
but mmm straws are illegal now shots are
[ __ ] bad for the environment [ __ ]
straws [ __ ] straws drink your drinks
like people with your mouths I was in
college I got a call from my buddy it
says I was at the University of Florida
it was a day before Halloween I got a
phone call and my buddy said hey a bunch
of us are going over to Todd's dorm todd
todd
he was cool as [ __ ] Izzie Cooper wanted
to be friends with Todd ever so I was
excited just about the invite for Todd I
was like okay I'm in then they were like
we're all gonna take acid Oh
and they were like then we're gonna
watch the movie An American Werewolf in
London and I wasn't listening to the
second half as much as I was the first
because I was so excited about Todd and
then I was like hooray for acid so I'm
like I'm in there's no question I'm
going we get over there it's me and so
Todd lived in a sweet dorm not actually
like sweet W like a sweet so it's like
so it's a it's one of those where it's
like two dorms and there's a living room
Todd had his own Todd had a [ __ ]
apartment Todd sounds dope Todd was cool
as [ __ ] I was super excited just to be
invited when we arrived everyone took
two tabs what two tabs of acid is that a
lot that's a lot too much for children
that's too much it's two two tabs too
much for children college freshmen and
then as we took we took it then we had a
couple of beers waiting for it to begin
and then as it started to kick in
somebody put a DVD version of American
Werewolf in London into a DVD player and
it got very weird very fast one of our
buddies got convinced that the
combination of the drugs and the movie
was going to transform him into an
actual werewolf and he alerted everyone
in the room in a very calm man from the
back of the room stood up anyway
hey guys that I'm about to change a
[ __ ] werewolf just muttered it into
the [ __ ] night and the rest of us
hear this and we're like oh [ __ ] what's
happening we're losing it that put a
that put something in our minds that
you're already werewolf yes everybody
just started thinking you were gonna
turn everyone was like oh my god
possibility of replicated if it got
Kevon we're do it got all of us and so
what
Kevin started doing this he freaked out
you're good he freaked out and he was
like I have to take off my clothes no
because I don't want to [ __ ] my clothes
up
why do you think they were they he's not
even rip through his clothes we turned
in like the monster well what was Todd
doing this whole time it's hard with
Chile's [ __ ] was this Todd's first time
to another state this was Don Todd's
first
how old was time we had 40 year old man
sophomore sophomore he could have been a
40 year old man no dude
so Kevin starts taking all his clothes
he's like starts with his shoes he's
like he literally went I just bought
these Nikes I mean it starts removing
them and then somebody from behind me
goes just turn the movie off and I went
that's fair that's a good way to fix
this and then somebody else went we're
probably all infected there's no fixing
it so then everyone went we loved our
clothes so now it's just a group a
roomful of college-age dudes removing
all of their clothing just stripping
down like well I can't lose this shirt
and my grandma bought me these jeans and
[ __ ] so everyone's stripping down and I
am in a full panic I'm like cold sweats
I grabbed the dorm room telephone and I
called 911 but at the same time listen
it wasn't because I was like oh I was
like it doesn't matter if we get in
trouble in my mind I was I assumed there
was about to be 10 monsters running
around the campus of the University of
Florida and killing people and I thought
that someone should know and I got on
the phone with the 911 operator and I
said I honestly told her I was like hi
me and my friends are on drugs and we're
all about to turn into werewolves
and we need help and the lady no like
right after I said it just very calmly
with honey tonight's not the full moon
[Music]
just set it like so calmly
this is the best zero
she's the best honestly I don't remember
your name but wherever you are in
Gainesville Florida her to hurt she's
the best 9-1-1 operator just quelled on
the inside just shut it down cuz he's
what have it I listen to her say that
and then wet oh no we're on drugs and
hung up the phone came back and then I
looked at we're gonna be fine guys it's
not the full moon and everyone went well
then we'll just put our clothes back on
and then it was just 20 minutes of
everyone putting their clothes back on
and then it was an amazing trip see
that's why you should never do
hallucinogenic drugs inside agreed I did
it once so I did it a month ago inside
and it was fine but it wasn't fun right
like I definitely cried on the floor
listening to Prince
and I was listening to I want to be your
lover and I just crying and being like I
get it somebody's loved her like crying
versus at like 4:00 in the morning being
outside you're like everything is great
as a trip I grabbed her with that find a
safe place outside yeah trip inside
don't be inside go outside oh my god
that was a super fun run of that
intoxicated stories guys and we're to
jump into another fun game which is
great because we're all shit-faced
cheers everybody bang bang bang bang
bang bang
let's do sketchy partners yeah
here is your any my blindfold so this
game is basically me and Chris are gonna
put blindfolds on we're going to hold
and touch objects and then Brendan and
Jenny are going to draw those objects
the winner scribe as we describe them
obviously the winner do we have a prize
for them no dry eraser markers yes hey
we didn't say we're professionals we
said we had a show and we bring you into
our weird basement and you can drink
free booze marijuana all right all right
burbank's nice who tell them where it's
at where Burbank studios are they gonna
find our weird basement they're gonna
find us you guys look like a couple of
Ninja Turtles because our guts are about
the size of the [ __ ] shell you eat
all their pizza in the front okay he's
got the ball you guys ready
you bet you just start all right don't
[ __ ] sass us Jenny all right
ayahuasca Queen here we go ready that's
not mine
do you have yours Chris yeah okay I
smelled it did you see a Jimmy I also
saw mine oh well the we just [ __ ] the
game well you guys pulled it out like
this but you didn't say that you turned
your back today you turned her back to
me and then telling this now cos holding
a [ __ ] parrot
a can of cheese wait what the [ __ ] it is
I would have taken ten minutes to
describe it you're not part of the game
plan that he's hope all right well [ __ ]
that game we're back in it y'all [ __ ] in
the box game some say we can't play the
box game we don't have anything in the
box guys did you know the cheese raised
in the box what's the difference between
me touching it and you showing it to me
you literally went like this that was
really good Jenny wins the game Oh
sideways I went to art school and this
is a really cool art school I did have a
BFA that sounds made up
it's not Mason's dick that's a wiener
are you writing your writing Cheez Whiz
but I don't care what your that's where
it comes out I'm gonna coach a nozzle
yeah your company comes out you drink
it's a dick but are you really drawing
me Jenni oh no I feel like put a front
of Chris there you go
did you say put it further back you turn
on my [ __ ] hairline
he's a [ __ ] he didn't start oh my
gosh we frame this big picture oh my god
your girlfriend put it on the fridge
Cheez Whiz it sounds like a terrible
rapper's name please spell it mmm well
now it's been sketchy partners everybody
let's do the drawing actually when we
come back from our wasty video we're
gonna see her drawing so let's go right
in the way see huh
[Music]
oh my god if you've just watched what we
created it is the most delicious-looking
thing in the entire planet Chris please
describe it because I don't know what it
is and I was lying you grab it as you
stop choking I was thinking it there
sorry oh it's two pieces of bread with
Nutella spread and excuse me
I'm marshmallow fluff and then you
microwave it and then you need to [ __ ]
it's not a grilled cheese sandwich it's
a grilled cheese yeah
Massachusetts everywhere fluff is made
poor man's wine oh we're doing indoor I
guess poor man is uh not a good Google
check that [ __ ] sir it's from
Massachusetts how can you even find it
is it how do I have to eat it I just
like this would you like to bite it No
Jenny's out she doesn't want the biting
is it bad
it's not good with the bread it's trash
it's really bad yeah it's called a
fluffer no no no this and peanut butter
is called a fluffernutter sandwich ever
heard of it I'm gonna [ __ ] disagree
your bread laughs peanut butter white
bread fluff or not you dilute the bread
give me a graham cracker well it's a
mess absolutely [ __ ] mess but whole
quite a waste he is you make it on your
home you know that like you've got a
couple things you mixed together how do
you not have graham crackers what would
you keep my way the widest thing
anyone's ever gonna make Costco how do
you not have graham crackers were you
some sort of monster you never went to
graham cracker house she's like an EBT
s'more that's okay
you know you're not helping a case about
sounding White T's for no losers job at
Disney no [ __ ] good
try with an Oreo you guys are missing
out this is it you talk to be the bread
[ __ ] do some work [ __ ] the bread oh
you read your minds great I'm
gluten-free oh [ __ ] I got it Oh ladies
and gentlemen my dearest apologies to
people who were gluten intolerant our
show is not meant for you we want to
McDouble and make chicken and may the
middle one saying we understand I made
those yeah would me [ __ ] I made those
yeah it's a McCollum Oh what is it
welcome to make ducking I'm a Duggan
there's no ducking it but go to the
drive-thru a I asked for all that [ __ ]
and it was just me they were like just
what's happening to that tiny man try it
out cuz you're gonna fly and fluff all
over I think they're napkins or anything
in the napkins I don't think there are
there were napkins chrisandem he was
just hoarding them alright cuz I'm sorry
it's sponsored by the word [ __ ] yeah
Chris is a cut oh god I wish it was know
what's hit it yet
oh no it's gonna be all snapper oh oh
this is that the word a brawl this
liquor does seem like it's like
somebody's like cough syrup brawl
spritzer it's gross
good god I see some more rum yeah I'll
give you some more rum the dark yeah I'm
having a diet coke and then a diet coke
dad Kirk thank you oh yeah you got it
already
all right oh yeah me and Brent we're
gonna take a shot what's the next part
oh yeah what we're gonna get to the next
part now I'm here to just keep the ship
moving Jenny's continuing the tradition
of every guest we've had and being
better host than me and Chris are and
please let us know how bad we're doing
internet because we give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
we'll get there suck my [ __ ] dick
write your [ __ ] comments you little
[ __ ] friends gonna look at all of
them here make this boy cry you wanna
make this boy cry make me cry I want to
[ __ ] read them look at those tears
falling down this guy's butt porcelain
fish vape look at this old new face in
the corner here all right we're dropping
into our I think this is my favorite
game
I love playing its the end every time
boos out that's who I am
okay I love booze we're gonna haul yeah
you have yeah yeah bud little bug little
buds noticed um we're gonna play a game
where all of us we're gonna get a clue
what happened you're just enjoying me
arm around Rachel I'm like Goldilocks
pcommunity bears he's talking about this
one I'm like I'm an otter you are not
between two fat guys ever put that
comment out between two fat guys that's
a killer come here welcome to you don't
have to say I'm meeting you
that's a queen two fat guys we're
jumping into our final game I know it's
funny way to show with the kid willy
wonka the Banzai he just won is it going
[Music]
Action Bronson in the [ __ ] gross
I tell you what the whoever wins BYOB
gets the cart yeah because we never hid
the secret word
Oreo cream comedy funny for stand-up
jokes
so venereal disease conference hey hey
we're not doing it yeah don't give it to
us drugs
otter otter 12-step meeting no no this
isn't the drunkest I've been I think JC
and I and that you losers when we said
we have two steps welcome to my rock
bottom rock bottom
oh stop you pretty pretty boys my dogs
are with that crew cut that out that
masculine birds already destroyed yeah
what does the accent just know how I
ever heard that bit I think he's making
it up no I all right moving on to our
final game I've got tapes someone's got
a taste of a lot of we have a job reopen
that we're a blank blank
we look like blank blank
I don't I do my opening joke is everyone
here if they've seen me walk out of a
public restroom automatically assumes
I've just taken a [ __ ] I do put my last
name
my last names copenhefer yeah I said
that changing the cope and I say Kobe
net was originally German it was
originally spelled with a k two peas and
a couple swastikas and from that story
you said in lakeland florida it makes a
lot of sense they go lesbian Jimmy
Neutron they're skinnier Adele we do not
doesn't relate me more a [ __ ] got
really skinny or how I wanted to play
Monica Lewinsky the Lifetime movie which
I remember a state at a his number
couchsurfing sure we do that oh yeah
tester come calm Oh like you're looking
at okay put you up yeah that's a
dangerous thing I remember was like it
was in London and then I was like in
Liverpool and they were like he's like
you of the Monica Lewinsky what ask to
get your dick so weird
let me show you love to show you what a
president I'm sorry
good job Chris we're to jump into our
final gas it's called beer on bartender
we're gonna get a clue from my
production staff and they're going to
tell us that clue and then we have to
try and figure out what cocktail that is
we're gonna give the name and a clue
about it
and then we're all gonna make a drink
and then I I'm gonna taste every one of
them and I'm gonna pick a winner based
on correctness and I'm taste okay we're
diving in guys here we are
Tino's come what's it patitos and arrive
late but it's here jumping into our
final game for your own bartender so
we're gonna create a cocktail we're
gonna we're gonna make it ourselves so
we're gonna get a name
a clue what's the name of it okay okay
I've never heard of this cocktail so
we're gonna have and again what how much
time do we have on the clock
90 seconds let how many ice up wait oh
Jenny wait what all right everybody nice
and then we ruin gets ice and then we
start you can hold the bottle but do not
put it in yet hold the bottle hold on to
it the name again was blood and sand and
the clue was blood and sand something I
put that much look at 90 seconds on the
clock let's see get ready the scene gets
close this and let's see who makes the
tastiest one rock and roll go the
Shambala for the Shambala Bourbon give
it a nice rest we're one minute game I'm
gonna actually put some of this into
another liqueur may be a very heavy
cocktail I don't know I don't know wait
is there seltzer water
yep go test sometimes they'll make a
sometimes they'll be a set bottle just a
splash old JC careful
let's see what happen ten seconds I give
mine a gentle shake make sure to release
if you got foundation no I told you lose
your release of touch of carbonation
okay I pour it now George all one yeah
mine's not short but yeah you can pour
into a shorter at all sorry Brenda help
me yeah
looking very oh your Britain's his is
like [ __ ] kool-aid mines on the rocks
my put a lie okay wait was a judge let's
let's go one by one Chris what did you
want star daddy you can ladies ladies
first you oh I don't know Bacardi
Bacardi black cranberries cranberry
oranges oranges I love the oranges
Kahlua Kahlua hmm
good boy and soda water you know that
wrestle [ __ ] felts a kid it smells
great oh and a grenadine it for ya hello
cherry
it's an odd flavor hey what else like a
try let me try it Jimmy
I was this is good right from the tap
Diana it's pretty [ __ ]
pretty Brenda Sydney it's pretty
mediciney I'm Alana they said 1922 this
was established in 1936 Kahlua friends
the drink detective man remark whatever
yeah I'll jump in here
I'm sorry I'm the cut now what do you
gotta shake a baby though
well you said you good I stirred my baby
Tanqueray gin a little bit of God
cranberry I just some Reds do you think
God cranberry what no it's got a little
bit of cranberry it's got tango a gin
what else there's some red thing I added
to it
grenadine no [ __ ]
or the Chambord Chambord is berry
liqueur and then orange then an orange I
like the orange let's get a fruity
bouquet I don't hate that I don't hate
that Chris always makes good drinks
they're always too sweet I like sweet
that's good hold it up tall a tall glass
everyone else for just a baby I like
that you poured a full one that went all
Bacardi but he went light in dark car
these are bloody put cranberry in I put
the grenadine in and a little bit of
that guy the pepper all have our own
what is that bro
I'm confused by it it is a to liqueur
from label it says it right there you
don't have to be a detective to really
to do a big 1823
it's very it's like a what's the what's
the what's the see one intelligence or
small skewed not cop or email I you know
what wrecker I think I like yours better
but you all you did is a strong poor hmm
it's not terrible though I still have to
go [ __ ] face off and I'm gonna pick
myself this time even though that is I
would I went bourbon and then I went
with the raspberry you know what that is
look cooler played a touch of the Aperol
I did a splash of ginger ale see how it
goes I don't think it's gonna be good
but I don't think it'd be terrible
yeah but you can't pick your own as the
best one we can it says show our show
show show and I think more than anything
else is bland
I can wait a linguist dick that drink is
extremely bland but it has so much booze
in it bill bill agree gland is blank but
there's tons of booze in it tastes like
it's from Bed Bath and Beyond
Jenny [ __ ] on all the drinks I'm [ __ ]
baked so there's so much alcohol in it
but it's bland
it smells like an organic do let's hear
what the actual drink is and then I'll
tell you guys which one I actually like
to drink the best thank you
Oh mine had orange in it so though mine
didn't warrant you answer for
we also have no orange juice so now they
set us up to [ __ ] fish I call this I
don't even see if it moves
so double-double [ __ ] us how could we
evade it want to put that on you guys
I'm gonna declare the winner Brenton
Brendan's the winner flavor-wise I liked
his the best oh [ __ ] I'm so sorry Jenny
the table if you flip the table right
now it would be the best episode we've
ever [ __ ] there's a card he took I do
I do
hey Thank You bonsai thanks for donating
this to the show so I'm Thank You
Brenton for giving away his winnings
okay where can we find you guys at throw
throw your social media out there follow
all things comedy [ __ ] yeah homes
I don't tweet though well start yeah man
you gotta say yeah follow all things
comedy follow at the Comedy Store or
follow at B becomes oh hi um get
everything at jenny zigrino calm that
spelled Vig rin oh my Instagram is great
all right again [ __ ] right lines up
my dog koppenhaver what do you got uh
you can find me everything Instagram
atwitter is at Chris cope comedy website
is at WME got Chris cope comedy calm you
find me at JC stand-up on twitter and at
JC comedian on instagram
and thank you guys for sticking around
and watching a bunch of people get
[ __ ] hammered and we're all getting
lifts just so you know about zero Oh
boots are we get over the lips we're all
getting lips so don't drink and drive be
safe Cheers bring me anyway every single
night Christmas every single like spray
my secretaries are always just so
paranoid the comment like it all right
guys say goodbye Oh bye all right
there's been another episode of impaired
it's been wonderful
I do
[Music]